[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRETT HESTERBERG: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Good conference so far.
Yeah?
Thank you all for coming
out, especially pretty late
in the afternoon on Day 2.
Hopefully, you've
enjoyed today's talks.
And we've got one
more for you here.
This is IO303, Best
Practices for Migrating
to Cloud SQL for MySQL.
So this is going to be
a MySQL-focused talk.
My name is Brett Hesterberg.
I'm a product manager here at
Google working on Cloud SQL.
GABRIELA FERRARA: And I'm Gabby.
I'm a developer advocate,
mostly working with database
and storage and Cloud SQL.
BRETT HESTERBERG: And
we're going to obviously
be talking today about migration
strategies going from a MySQL
server that you manage
yourself to Cloud SQL.
And more than just talking about
it, we're going to be doing it,
or more directly,
Gabby's going to be doing
it live with an application.
Before we jump into
the subject matter,
we'd love to learn a
little bit more about you.
By a show of hands, how
many of you are developers?
A good chunk of the room here.
OK.
How about DevOps engineers?
And DBAs, database
administrators?
Good handful here.
How about reluctant
database administrators?
Oh, even more.
And do we have any
managers in the audience?
I think we've got some overlap.
Certainly the fractions
were adding past one there.
OK, thanks for that feedback.
A couple more questions.
Just by a show of
hands, how many of you
attended Next last year?
OK, a good percentage.
And how many of you,
as of this moment,
are managing a MySQL server?
A good chunk of room, great.
All right.
Well, I think we've got
a good content for you.
The feedback certainly helps
us shape this as we go along.
Let me start with
the big picture.
What are we going to be not
only talking about today,
but also building today?
What you see in this
diagram is a MySQL server
that can be just about anywhere
in the world with a replication
pairing to a Cloud SQL replica.
We've got an application
at the bottom, which
is reading and writing to
our external MySQL server,
while the Cloud SQL
replica is keeping up
with changes, with writes,
updates, inserts being
made to the external server.
What we're going to be doing
as part of our application
migration is essentially
failing into Cloud SQL.
And you see that depicted in
this diagram, where now, we've
changed some things.
The replication
direction has changed.
So we have Cloud SQL as
our primary instance,
and we have our external
MySQL server as our replica.
And we've re-pointed
our application.
Our application is now both
reading, and more importantly,
writing to Cloud SQL as
the primary instance.
From there, of course, we can
configure things in Cloud SQL,
ask Cloud SQL to do tasks like
high availability for us, which
is also depicted in the diagram.
So that's our big picture today.
What we're doing
this on is the back
of a fairly new feature for us.
We're very happy to formally
announce external server
support for Cloud SQL,
for MySQL here at Next.
This just went GA last week.
So you'll see this in
our public documentation.
And for those of you who
currently use Cloud SQL,
you'll see a brand
new button in your UI,
in our Cloud Console, which
is highlighted on this slide.
And it's Migrate Data.
We're going to be using the UI
today to migrate our database.
Like everything in Cloud
SQL, if it's in the UI,
it's also in the
CLI and the API.
So depending on what you like
to use to manage Cloud SQL
instances, you'll be able to do
exactly what we're doing today.
Again, we'll just go
ahead and use the UI.
OK, before we get
too far in, I'm
going to talk just a
little bit about how
Cloud SQL fits into Google's
database portfolio overall.
We'll get into just a bit about
what Cloud SQL is and is not.
And then we'll go to the
heart of our subject matter,
which is migration.
And we'll do a live
database migration today.
As you see on this slide, Google
has a broad database portfolio.
Rightmost on the slide are
our third party or partner
offerings that are database
specific on Google Cloud.
Google Cloud generally has
a large partner ecosystem.
The list of third party
databases you see here
is not comprehensive.
There are many other offerings.
This is a selection
that gives you
a feel for some of the
databases available.
As you look leftmost
on the slide,
to our in-memory
database category,
our Cloud Memorystore
team very recently
launched Redis
support into beta.
So if you do have
caching needs and you're
interested in a managed
Redis, we have that now
in Cloud Memorystore.
Just right of center is
our relational portfolio
in the database portfolio.
And you see Cloud Spanner
as well as Cloud SQL.
Cloud Spanner, if you
haven't had a chance
to go to any talks about
Spanner at this conference,
I encourage you to do so.
It's a great product
to learn about.
Cloud SQL's mission in
the database portfolio
is to be compatible.
We are offering as close to
unmanaged MySQL and Postgres
as we possibly can so that if
your application works today
with MySQL or with Postgres, it
will just work with Cloud SQL.
In addition to
the compatibility,
Cloud SQL aims to manage
the mundane aspects
of administration associated
with a MySQL server
or a Postgres server.
And we'll talk a little bit
about those mundane aspects
as we get into the presentation.
Tim Kelton, from Descartes
Labs is a Cloud SQL user.
And I think Tim sums up
Cloud SQL fairly well.
He's saying for his
team, they choose
to use Cloud SQL
because it allows
them to focus on other things.
It allows them to
focus on things
that have more value for their
business and their customers.
Tim's worrying a bit less
about database administration.
When I tend to
think of Cloud SQL,
I tend to think of the
technology stack that
goes into running a database.
Many of you raised
your hands when I asked
are you managing MySQL today.
So you know the stack or at
least some portion of the stack
pretty well.
The leftmost column in the
stack is the hardware column.
This is racking and stacking
servers, thinking about power
and cooling for the
servers and data center.
As you move to the
left, the next stack
is the operating system itself,
keeping that operating system
up to date with patches.
Move further right even than
that, and now we finally
get to the database.
Beyond installing
the database itself,
we've got to patch the
database, make sure it's secure,
and do things like taking
regular backups for data
protection.
Finally rightmost on the diagram
is where things get interesting
and we get into some
advanced functionality, using
replication, for example,
for high availability,
or read scale-out, and
thinking about things
like, how do we determine if a
primary instance is unhealthy.
What should we do
about failover?
Should it be a manual
task or an automatic task?
All of this then gets
wrapped into monitoring,
where we want to
make sure we know
what's going on with our stack.
What Cloud SQL aims to do is
take this set of technology,
the technology required
to run a database,
and turn it into
a single API call
so that as a DevOps
engineer, a developer, a DBA,
with a single API
call, you can bring up
a very simple development
database or a much more
complex production database
with high availability,
automatic failover,
read scale-out.
What is not shown
in this diagram
is what backs the
Cloud SQL service.
And Jason from RealMassive,
another Cloud SQL user,
points this out.
Cloud SQL is backed
by a 24 by 7 SRE team.
These are the folks who
write the automation
and the monitoring to keep
Cloud SQL's fleet of databases
healthy.
And when needed, they're the
folks who get on the keyboard
and bring an unhealthy
database back to life.
Jason's pointing
out here that this
is one less thing for his team
to worry about so that they can
focus their attention
again on other things
that they believe
have more value.
With that overview
of Cloud SQL in mind,
we'll get into
migration options.
If you are running a
MySQL today and you
wish to migrate that
server, that MySQL database,
to Cloud SQL, you have
essentially a simple option
and a more advanced option.
What I'll start by saying
is whenever possible,
take the simple approach.
It works, and it's
straightforward operationally
to implement.
The simple approach is this.
I have my running MySQL
instance, my server
that I'm running today
and managing myself.
I set it to read only mode.
My application now can no
longer write to the database.
The database data itself
is frozen in time.
I ask the database
to export that data,
or dump in MySQL terminology,
so I get all the data set,
which is currently frozen.
And when I have that, I
take it, and I upload it
to Google Cloud
Storage, for example,
as a way to get it
into Google Cloud.
Then I ask Cloud SQL,
import this data set.
When Cloud SQL is done,
I repoint my application
at Cloud SQL and begin
accepting writes.
It's a very simple approach.
There is one obvious consequence
of this approach, right?
Which is?
AUDIENCE: Downtime.
BRETT HESTERBERG: Downtime,
and potentially a lots of it.
There are ways to
reduce downtime
and where, if you're thinking
about a simple approach,
an application
that is reasonably
tolerant of downtime, you can
minimize the amount of time
you're down by really
focusing on how
to optimize the import time.
Importing data into a database
can be very time consuming.
So this is showing three general
themes to optimize and import.
Let's start first with
optimizing your schema
for import.
Here, it's all
about handling keys.
As a starting point, import your
data without secondary keys.
You can recreate indexes
after you've imported.
Second item here is import
your data in primary key order.
This has real consequences
when writing data
or importing into a database.
The second theme you see here
is optimize your Cloud SQL
instance for import.
Cloud SQL can be
scaled very small.
It can also be
scaled very large.
And what I'm
recommending here is,
think about allocating
CPUs, and RAM,
and storage performance
to Cloud SQL
so that it has the
infrastructure, the resources,
to run fast during an import.
Also note that while I think
scaling CPUs and RAM is very
straightforward-- more CPUs,
more RAM generally equals more
performance--
in Google Cloud, we
tie storage performance
to storage capacity.
So if you want more
IOPS, more capacity
is how you get those IOPS.
If you know you have a
200-gigabyte database,
allocate 200 gigs or more
of storage to that instance
so that you immediately
get the IOPS.
I say that because Cloud
SQL has an option that
allows you to tell Cloud SQL,
grow the disk on my behalf.
And you can start an import
of a 200-gigabyte database
with a 10-gigabyte disk.
Cloud SQL will happily grow
the disk incrementally for you
as you do the import.
What you won't get is the
performance of the 200-gig disk
until you reach
that capacity level.
And then lastly in
this theme, turn off
an advanced feature like binary
logging for the import, which
has a right
consequence, has a right
overhead associated with it.
Last theme here is know how
to monitor the import process.
Cloud SQL comes with a set
of basic performance metrics
that we show in
the Cloud Console.
Know how to look at those.
And watch out for reads.
We're doing an import.
We should be just
mostly writing.
If we're doing a
lot of reads, that
indicates the
database is paging.
We're exhausting our buffer.
And we're making the database
do a lot of extra work
during import.
So these three themes,
these three ways
to optimize your
import, can reduce
the amount of
downtime associated
with our simple migration.
One note here is
that after import, we
can undo some of these things.
So I asked you to scale your
instance large for the import.
I'm not saying you have to
keep it there indefinitely.
That costs money every month.
Cloud SQL allows you to
very easily to remove
CPUs and remove RAM.
So you don't have to
keep a large instance
in the long term.
Scaling at large just for import
can be a very cost effective
way to gain performance.
After import, you can
turn on binary logging.
Binary logging Cloud SQL uses
for some advanced features
like high availability,
point-in-time recovery, things
that we think you should use.
So go ahead and turn
that on after import.
And then, of course, add
your indexes back as needed.
We talked about disabling some
of that before the import.
Bring those back now that
you've got your data there.
OK, those are general import
performance optimization steps
as a way to limit the
downtime associated
with our simple migration.
Now, many of you saw right
through the simple migration
and said, that's great for
some non-critical apps I have.
What about my critical
apps that aren't
very tolerant of downtime?
What do I do?
And that's really the
focus of our talk today.
We'll go through
it conceptually.
And then we're
going to do it all
together live with
an application
that Gabby has written.
This diagram shows
how we're going
to minimize downtime today
with our live app migration.
You have an application pointing
at your existing MySQL server.
It's doing reads and writes.
And it's a live application.
We're going to tell that
existing MySQL server,
do an export of your data,
do a dump of your data
as it exists right now.
The database starts
doing that export.
We don't stop the database
from accepting new writes.
New writes are coming in.
Updates and inserts
are coming in.
We get the export out, which
is now a little bit stale.
We send it off to
Google Cloud Storage.
And we import it into Cloud SQL.
This process may take minutes
if you're really lucky,
hours, which is
common, maybe even
days if you have a lot of data.
So you now have a
Cloud SQL instance that
has a data set that's stale.
It doesn't have any of
the updates, inserts
that have been going on while
we're doing this process.
The upside is, our app
been up the whole time.
Our users are still happy.
What we do here to catch
up the Cloud SQL instance
is set up a replication
relationship
between your existing
MySQL Server and Cloud SQL.
We've called this external
server replication,
where your external server is
still the primary instance.
It's still accepting new
reads and new writes.
And that's the important
bit here is the new writes.
Cloud SQL, once it
begins to replicate
from your external server,
is starting to catch up now.
It says, OK, I'm
four hours behind.
I've got some work to do.
And it begins to catch up.
All the while, your
external MySQL server
continues to serve traffic.
So we've had no
downtime thus far.
Once we know our
Cloud SQL replica is
in sync with our
external MySQL server--
the two have the same data set.
The last transaction I wrote
here to my external server
is now in Cloud SQL--
now we can make our failover.
Now we can make our move.
We set our external
server to read only.
We say freeze the
data set as it is.
We make sure that our Cloud
SQL replica has that data.
And then we break the
replication connection.
Now, we repoint our
application to Cloud SQL.
And we tell Cloud SQL,
become the primary instance.
Start accepting writes.
You are now the
primary instance.
Our application begins
happily writing again.
And we've migrated
into Cloud SQL,
or failed over, if you
will, to the cloud,
with minimal downtime.
The key here is
that this process
minimizes downtime for a
database of essentially
any size.
What you saw here is we were
keeping our external MySQL
server, our old
primary, up as long
as we needed to make sure we
could get the data to Cloud SQL
and that Cloud SQL could
catch up via replication.
This works on large data
sets as well as small data
sets to limit downtime.
So it's one thing
to talk about this.
But let's start to
see this in action.
Gabby has an application
based on a LAMP stack, so
a very common stack that
we see folks using this
as a single VM that
includes the MySQL database,
Apache web server, PHP.
And we happen to be
running what is becoming
a very popular WordPress site.
So Gabby's WordPress
site started small.
She's now gotten a lot
of additional traffic.
And you'll see why
when you see this site.
She has decided to scale.
She needs to take MySQL and
that workload off of this server
and send it to Cloud SQL.
So we've got our
current state here.
We are on a single GCE VM.
One thing to note
here is that this
could be physical hardware.
This could be a server
somewhere in the world.
This could be a VM
in some other cloud.
The point here is that
Gabby has full control
over the database in this VM.
She desires to move
to a world where
she's offloaded all the MySQL
load to Cloud SQL, where
her VM now is
simply a web server
with a connection to Cloud
SQL for its database needs.
And we're going to get into
exactly how to do this.
In fact, we're gonna
do it live on this URL.
Sorry about that for
the errant click.
If you wish to follow along, if
you want to see for yourself,
what does downtime look
like, what does this app look
like as we're doing this,
fire up your mobile device,
browse to this URL.
What you'll find is Gabby
has created a WordPress site
that has the listings of every
Google Cloud Next 2018 session.
So obviously, it's a hot site.
And it's now struggling
under its own load.
You can watch us do this live.
We'd love to get your
traffic as we go along.
So make sure you see when
the site is down, exactly
for how long it's down,
and when it comes back up.
Gabby?
GABRIELA FERRARA: Just a moment.
Thank you, Brett.
BRETT HESTERBERG: Wait.
Let me give the URL
up on the screen here.
Oops.
Can you switch it back
just for a moment.
GABRIELA FERRARA: OK.
AUDIENCE: We can see it.
GABRIELA FERRARA: You can see?
OK.
So this is a WordPress
that I imported the data
from all of the Google
Cloud Next sessions.
For now, you can just
browse through it.
It's working.
It's on a single VM
on Compute Engine.
And today, we're going to
migrate that MySQL server
from the VM to the Cloud SQL.
For purposes of
clarity, I'm going
to be calling primary
the server on the VM,
and replica the one that we're
going to be setting up now.
So Brett showed you the new
menu on the SQL dashboard
on the console.
So once you access the SQL menu,
you can see Migrate Data here.
And as we said,
you're going to be
using the UI to be doing this.
But you can also use
the API or the CLI.
Once you start to
begin migration,
you need a couple of data.
And you need to have prepared
your server for this.
One of the things
that we require
is for you to have binary
logging on on your primary,
and also have GTID enabled so we
know which last transaction was
executed on the server.
It wants to generate
the down point for it.
So I'm going to create it here.
I'm going to zoom in.
So name of the
data set, I'm going
to put next2018-migration-d.
So the IP address that
I have for that website
is the same VM from that.
That address is this one.
Yes, I'm copying.
Well, you also need to have
a replication user set up
on your primary server
to have the permissions
necessary to copy all the data.
In this case, I created
a replication user
called Replication.
And I'm going to click here
so you don't see my password.
Once you set up that, you need
to make sure that the database
version that you're using--
we are supporting MySQL
5.6 and 5.7 for migration.
So in my case, it's
MySQL 5.7 on the VM,
so I'm going to just
keep it as it is.
And if you use certificates
for SSL and TLS,
you can set up in here
and on your certificate.
In my case, I'm not using it.
When you click on
Next, it's going
to ask you for the name of the
replica you'll be creating.
I'm going to keep the
name they proposed to me.
It's the same name
as the primary that's
with called SQL added to it.
Another important
thing is if you
know where your server
is, it's ideal for you
to get a database
server that's closer
to it, the same region, or even
the same zone, if possible.
In my case, if I look on
the Compute Engine instance,
I am on US Central,
and my zone is F.
So the latency
doesn't get too high,
I'm going to keep
it on the same zone.
As Brett mentioned too, you
can scale up for this import.
And I'm going to choose a 2
CPU with 7 and 1/2 gigabytes
of RAM.
The ideal proportion is if
you have a 5 gigabyte set,
get at least instance with
at least 10 gigabytes so you
can load all the
memory and don't
have any problems with that.
As I said before, you need to
have GTID and binary logging
enabled.
You need to generate a file on
MySQL Dump using the MySQL Dump
comment.
And once you've
generated that file,
you're going upload it to Google
Cloud Storage on a bucket.
The bucket's
private so you don't
need to worry about security.
And you just choose
which file it
is that's going to be imported.
As I said before, this does
have the information's GTID
and binary logging that's going
to be used for replication.
If you're going to be
connecting to this database
with [INAUDIBLE]
called SQL proxy, which
[INAUDIBLE] binary
application to be
transparent for
connection, it makes
your application think
that the server is local,
you can also whitelist
an IP address.
In this case, I'm going to
whitelist the IP address off
the VM data we were using.
So you need to give a name.
In this case it's Application.
And I'm going to use the same
IP address as the database
because they are
on the same server.
BRETT HESTERBERG:
So one point here
is that Cloud SQL comes
with a built-in firewall.
And what Gabby's doing right
now is telling Cloud SQL's
firewall, allow a connection
from this particular address,
which is her application server.
If we don't do this, Cloud
SQL's going to block the network
connection.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Yeah,
you could, in theory,
whitelist all IP
addresses on the internet.
We don't recommend
you to do that.
BRETT HESTERBERG: Yeah, that is
an official non-recommendation.
GABRIELA FERRARA: We don't
recommend you to do that.
But for this example
here, we're just
going to whitelist the IP
off of the application.
Once you hit Create,
what's going to happen
is we're going to start
to provision an IP
address for this instance
that's being created.
This IP address that's
going to be created here,
it's not the IP address
we're going to use
to connect to the instance.
It's the IP address
we're going to use
to whitelist on
your primary server
through your firewall to allow
the connection to the database.
So you don't need to
put all your server
through the whole
internet to see.
So once that's
created, provision,
you'll be able in here to use
this IP address to whitelist
on your server.
Clicking on Next gives you more
information about promotion.
We'll skip that for
now and just create it.
Because this can take a
while, depending on your load,
on how big is your
data set, I already
baked our replica on the site.
So we're going to be connecting
here first to the local server.
And I want to show you how
many posts we have in here
and compare to the replica.
So in here, I have 456 posts.
And if replication is working,
it should have the same amount.
So let me connect here.
And the IP address is--
456.
But you're like, is the
replication really working?
I don't know.
BRETT HESTERBERG:
We should find out.
GABRIELA FERRARA: We
should find out soon.
One way to find out is
let's create a new post.
I will create a new post here.
Welcome to IO303 on Next.
Welcome.
It was successfully created.
So if you go to the page,
you'll see that scene there.
And let's see the count again.
So here on the local
post, we have 457.
So it added the new post.
And on the
replication, also 457.
So replication is working.
You could also use
the MySQL on commands
to see where on the
binary logging you are,
which was the last GTID.
This is just a simple
approach because it
shows a lot of variables on the
screen, and it's hard to read.
So next step is to freeze the
writes on our primary server,
because at some point,
either you stop the instance
and have actually a downtime.
And since this is an application
that's mostly read only,
you can just lock
the writes and be
able to go through the
migration to the new replica
and promote it to primary.
What I'm going to do for us to
have an idea of traffic here,
I'm going to simulate
a bit of traffic,
about 100 requests per second.
And then I'll do
the migration here.
BRETT HESTERBERG: And as a
quick aside, how many of you
are familiar with
Google Cloud Shell?
GABRIELA FERRARA: OK.
BRETT HESTERBERG: That's good.
We joke that it is Google
Cloud's best kept secret.
It's a VM that's provisioned
for you automatically.
You can use it to
explore your project
or even do some
development work.
And Gabby, you're using
it, it looked like,
to run a load generator.
Is that right?
GABRIELA FERRARA: Yes.
Because I had an
experience where
I was doing the load
out of my own machine,
and Google blocked me because
it thought I was spamming.
[LAUGHS]
So let's avoid that.
BRETT HESTERBERG: So
between your load generator,
and I'm sure many of you
are browsing the sessions
site that Gabby has
built to find out
where you're going
next tomorrow,
we've got some load on our site.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Yeah.
Right now, I just locked
the primary database.
And it should be still
reading, but it's not
going to do any writes.
If I tried to edit a post,
it's not going to work.
The next step for that is to
edit your connection string
on your application.
If you're using Kubernetes,
you can redeploy.
Or if you're using any
continuous deployment too,
you just change environment
variables and do that.
I'm going to go to a
simpler approach here.
I'm going to edit the file
because it's just a WordPress
installation.
And I do need to put again--
I'm going to replace
local host, which
it is, again, the
database [INAUDIBLE]
is on the same VM with the one
that we are setting up here.
It's not going to show anything.
But now, we should be
pointing to the replica.
We still have one
step to do, which
is to promote the
replica to primary
so we can have writes
again on your database.
So once you go back to the SQL
menu and access your primary--
I called primary here.
But when you access
your instance,
you see here this
button, Promote Replica.
And once you click
on there, it's
going to disable the read
only flag on your database,
just to accept the writes
that it wasn't before.
BRETT HESTERBERG:
And just after you
click here-- so
right now, what's
going on with the application?
Is anyone hitting it
with their mobile device?
Is it up?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BRETT HESTERBERG:
Up and running?
GABRIELA FERRARA: What?
BRETT HESTERBERG: I was
asking, what's going on
with the application right now.
GABRIELA FERRARA:
Yeah, it's working.
And while now it's
doing the promotion,
I'm sending more traffic to
it to see if we get any errors
or if it catches any downtime.
So let's see if--
at some point here,
it's going to finish.
BRETT HESTERBERG:
Yeah, so while Gabby's
doing the promotion again, I
think a couple key steps here.
One is we validated that data
on our former primary server,
our LAMP stack, exactly matched
that on our Cloud SQL replica.
We made sure that
the two were in sync.
Gabby did this by showing a
number of posts with WordPress.
There are a good
many ways to do this.
If you have a very
active application,
you'll need to set
your external MySQL
server in some read-only
mode so that the writes stop.
Then you can begin the cut over.
Gabby used a sed command
to substitute essentially
the IP address of the
Cloud SQL instance
in her WordPress config
file rather than local host
so that the application now
begins to shift and point
to Cloud SQL.
And then the key
step here was, what
Cloud SQL calls a
promotion, which is you
as an administrator
telling Cloud SQL, I want
to take this read replica,
which is read-only,
and promote it to become
a primary instance,
meaning accepting
reads and writes.
What Cloud SQL knows from
that point forward is,
this instance is no longer a
follower of something else.
This will accept writes
and blaze its own trail,
so to speak.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Yes.
Correct.
And right now, its promoting.
[LAUGHS]
And you can see the application
with downtime right now.
So if you try to access
the application right now,
it's having problems
accessing because it's not
finding the connection
with the database.
BRETT HESTERBERG: And this
is the cut over point.
And I think you're seeing
it in the audience.
Right now, the
application is down.
So this is when you would
schedule on the order of one
to three minutes of
downtime for the migration.
Gabby had shown you that
for the bulk of the process,
getting the data to Cloud SQL
and setting up replication,
your app is live.
You can do these things
during business hours.
When you're ready to cut over,
meaning when your application
is most tolerant of
downtime, then we
want to wrap up
with these steps.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Yes.
And I'm just waiting.
BRETT HESTERBERG: And
the key to any demo
is that it ends up working here.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Yeah,
that's the problem with those.
BRETT HESTERBERG: Generally,
a promotion in Cloud SQL
takes about one to two minutes.
As Gabby mentioned, we're
doing some configuration work
in MySQL itself, which
takes a bit of time,
and then we're doing some
configuration work in Cloud SQL
to essentially move this
replica to a full blown primary
instance.
One thing to note here while
we're watching the promotion
is that the external server
technology we've released
allows for the reverse
replication to happen as well,
meaning we can, as a
Cloud SQL primary server,
replicate to your
external server as well.
So effectively, you're
able to fail into Cloud SQL
and fail back out.
In case of a problem
with this migration path,
for example, you may wish
to re-promote your existing
server back to primary.
And this gives you,
essentially, an out when you're
going through this process.
We think it's
important to note this
because we want to make sure
that migration to Cloud SQL
is as easy in as it is out.
Cloud SQL compatible and open.
And we want to make sure that
you have as many on ramps
as you do off
ramps, so to speak.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Yeah.
Do we rollback?
[LAUGHS]
BRETT HESTERBERG: Yeah.
[LAUGHS] We have some
unhappy app users
right now who are desperate to
know about sessions tomorrow.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Yeah.
Let me try with
the other promotion
here, with the one that I
just created here with you.
This is the IP address.
I think what happened--
I don't know what happened.
I don't know.
Let's see.
I'm going to do the
same sed command.
And I'm going to change
the promotion here
for the other IP address.
OK.
And let's promote the
one that we just created
and see if it goes.
BRETT HESTERBERG: So
we'll see if we get
our promotion complete here.
And if we don't,
obviously, we've
got a bit more work to do.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIELA FERRARA:
You got it 200s?
That's good.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BRETT HESTERBERG:
For the questions,
and we're happy to
take a few questions
at this point of the
demo, if you can come up
to the mic that's in the
middle of the room, just
so everybody in
the room can hear
and so that we can make
sure we can hear as well.
GABRIELA FERRARA:
Yay, it worked!
[LAUGHTER]
The other one didn't,
but this one worked.
[LAUGHTER]
So now, let's see if--
I'm sorry for interrupting you.
So sorry.
Let's just do a final test here.
Let's edit a post.
I had a typo here on next.
Let's update it.
And let's see if on the front--
yes, the E is down again.
BRETT HESTERBERG: Yes.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Finally.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
I had reconfigured an instance
before so because I did not
know how long it would
take to get ready and not
make everybody wait.
And then I used the one that
I already had created before
to do the promotion.
Which, it didn't work.
So the one that I
created live here
was the one that actually
worked in the end.
BRETT HESTERBERG: OK, so
with that, Gabby, then,
what we saw is the final step.
A critical step is when
the application is down,
it's controllable
generally in time,
regardless of database size.
And in this case, we hung
on tight, and it worked.
Our application is
back up and running.
So thanks for the
patience there.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Yeah.
Thank you.
BRETT HESTERBERG: OK, so
to quickly wrap up then--
and we appreciate the
questions along the way--
we've ended up in a realized
state for our application
where we've moved MySQL
off of our single VM.
We've taken the M out
of our LAMP stack.
We've moved this load
now to Cloud SQL.
Our site's operational again.
And that's really the motivation
for this new functionality
in Cloud SQL.
It's very much this
kind of migration path,
where, as I mentioned, you
can do this in each direction.
You can migrate off of Cloud
SQL in this way as well.
A few next steps for you all.
As I mentioned at
the beginning, use
a simple approach for
migration whenever possible.
That will be for
non-critical applications
that are reasonably
tolerant of downtime.
Think about reducing
that downtime
by optimizing your import.
Generally, optimizing
your import,
whether you're using the
simple downtime migration
scheme or the more
advanced low downtime
migration that we
just demonstrated,
optimizing that import will
be wise in either case.
To get started with Cloud
SQL, if you're not already
using Google Cloud, I recommend
starting with a free trial.
You get 300 free
trial dollars, which
can be used on any product
in GCP, including Cloud SQL.
It's a great way to start
to learn GCP and Cloud
SQL as well.
A couple presentation
pics for you.
We are on Day 2
of the conference.
We've got some, I think, great
sessions tomorrow as well.
These are ones that caught my
eye, as well as Gabby's eye.
We have one about Reinventing
Databases for Your Journey
to the Cloud.
I think those of you who
are interested in Spanner,
and more generally, our
database portfolio at Google
would enjoy this session.
For one about how to
think like an SRE,
how to use Google
SRE for availability,
reliability, scalability
in hybrid environments,
this one is really appropriate,
especially where many of you
are contemplating
migrations to Google Cloud.
Google helped invent SRE.
And I think that
session will have a lot
to share around how we think
about these things in Cloud.
The last one on the
list, a tongue twister,
Computing with
Power not Previously
Possible with BigQuery
and Compute Engine--
this one really
describes what you
can do at big scale in
Google Cloud, lots of CPUs,
and with an application
like BigQuery.
With that, on behalf
of Gabby, I want
to thank you all for spending
a chunk of your afternoon
with us.
And we'd love to
open up to questions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]